you think it's just a drone what if I
say it hacked a large US company while
flying over there it was an ordinary day
for a financial company suddenly one
employee noticed unusual activity on the
atlassian Confluence internal service
the security service discovered that
someone within the radius of the Wi-Fi
network of the building was trying to
use the employee's Mac address after
tracking the Wi-Fi signal the team went
up to the roof and saw modified DJI
matrice 600 and DJI Phantom drones
equipped with a Wi-Fi pineapple a
powerful device used by cyber Security
Experts to test the vulnerabilities of
wireless networks and it allows
malicious agents to intercept internet
traffic the attack was a limited success
and it appears that once the attackers
were discovered they accidentally
crashed the drone on recovery watch our
experimental video with drone attacks
Link in the comments